- [Bran] Everything you did brought you
where you are now, where you belong.
- The creators of "Game of Thrones"
have signed a monumental
new deal with Netflix,
but can they live up to it?
We'll take a look right now on the new
Rotten Tomatoes show, "The Ketchup".
David Benioff and Dan Weiss are moving on
from HBO and will create and develop
new projects for the streaming giant
after signing a 200 million dollar
multi-year overall film and TV deal.
It's one of Netflix's biggest deals yet
and beat out other serious contenders
like Amazon, thought
to be the front runner
at one time, and Disney, with whom the duo
already have a deal to write
three "Star Wars" movies.
Benioff and Weiss, who created and served
as showrunners on HBO's
mega-hit "Game of Thrones"
are coming off a polarizing final season
that's a rotten 58% on the Tomato meter.
And even though it did
set a new Emmy record
for the most nominations
by a single program
in one year with 32, it
kinda makes you wonder
if the season suffered
'cause they were checked out
and already onto other projects,
and people on Twitter
don't seem that impressed
with Netflix giving
these guys a huge deal,
saying things like, "Benioff and Weiss
"have unique experience
in running a big budget
"show with lots of moving
parts, but I just can't
"see how they're worth
200 million dollars.
"They're not Ryan Murphy who produces like
"three original hits a year,"
and "Whispers, Benioff and Weiss were not
"the reason people liked
'Game of Thrones.'"
Then there's my personal favorite,
"Perhaps after it's all said and done,
"the greatest thing Benioff and Weiss ever
"gave us was the endless Lena Headey
"as Cersei Lannister gifs to respond to
"all of their future projects."
- Sometimes I wonder, if this
is the price for our sins.
- As far as what this means for HBO,
it's worth noting that
the two will be credited
as executive producers on any and all
"Game of Thrones" prequel
series moving forward,
and the upcoming series
"Confederate" which
the duo was set to write and serve
as showrunners on, is now off their books.
No word yet on if the contriversal project
will move to Netflix as
part of their new deal.
When it comes to "Star
Wars", the first film
in their trilogy has already been slated
for a December 16th 2022
release, with the others
most likely coming every
two years after that.
So when exactly the guys
will find time for new
Netflix projects seems to
be a pretty valid question.
- May the force be with you.
- And then there's Netflix.
This deal comes after
a wave of cancellations
for scripted shows like "The OA",
"She's Gotta Have It",
and "Designated Survivor",
not to mention seminal
female created shows
like "One Day at a Time",
and "Tuca and Bertie".
But with the streaming
wars just heating up
you gotta make room for
big moves considering
the company already has
deals with mega-producers
Ryan Murphy, Shonda
Rhimes, and Kenya Barris
among others.
- Whatever stands in our
way, we will defeat it.
- So, let me turn it over to you.
- What do you think, do Benioff and Weiss
deserv this big of a deal?
Did you have issues with the last season
of "Game of Thrones", or
did you secretly love it
and you just are ashamed to admit it?
You can tell us.
Let us know in the comment section,
and tell us what other stories you'd love
to see us cover, and for all the latest
streaming news head on
over to RottenTomatoes.com.
Thanks for watching our
new show, "The Ketchup",
where we explore what the latest news
from movies and TV means to you.
Until next time, I'm Mark Ellis.
(upbeat music)